remscheider county in den bergen von
west virginia gut zwei stunden von
amerikas hauptstadt entfernt das
ländliche amerika hier sind träumst
feuchte wähler zu hause
wir treffen sie beim gottesdienst wegen
corona unter freiem himmel limonade oder
kaffee gibt es gratis dazu
bibeltreue evangelikale bei der andacht
wie im autokino trump loben sie in den
höchsten tönen
er gibt sein bestes ich weiß dass er
dieses land liegt er gibt alles für
unser land würden sie ihn wieder wählen
oh ja ich war vom ersten tag an
glücklich mit ihm was mögen sie denn so
an ihm die tatsache dass er versucht ein
christliches leben zu führen
in amerika ticken die uhren anders auf
dem land hier gelten noch die
althergebrachten werte glaube familie
freiheit währte die die republikaner
verkörpern das gemeinschafts mal in der
3 in kirche pandemie bedingt einzeln
verpackt gruppen für jesus
ich schaue ihn an und denke trump ist
daran führe
wer das macht gott schickt uns eben ganz
unterschiedliche menschen ein paar
kilometer weiter betreibt michelle eine
kleine werkstatt sie ist durch und durch
republikanerin während der finanzkrise
unter obama ging sie pleite
die demokraten hatten nur den banken und
den großkonzernen schon dagegen schickt
in der korona krise jedem amerikaner
einen scheck der ihr tatsächlich
kundschaft bringt ihr gefällt oder nicht
er ist unser präsident
er verdient respekt was ich an trump am
meisten mag er ist kein politiker er
redet nicht wie einer er bewegt sich
nicht wie einer er benimmt sich nicht
wie eine genau das ertragen die schmidts
nicht mehr sie sind die ausnahme in west
virginia
sie betreiben eine pferdefarm vier
generationen unter einem dach alle haben
für hilary gestimmt und sehnen sich nach
einem wechsel
trump ist ihrer ansicht nach ein
böswilliger spaltpilz der politische
gegner zu feinden erklärt bei
begegnungen mit nachbarn gilt die devise
wir reden nicht über politik niemals
warum nicht es macht keinen sinn sie
hören nicht zu und fairerweise muss man
sagen wir hören ihnen wahrscheinlich
auch nicht zu zwei drittel der menschen
in west virginia haben für trump
gestimmt er verkörpert was den meisten
hier wichtig ist niedrige steuern
start gegen abtreibung dafür hängt er
großflächige hetztiraden auf demokraten
töten ungeborene grundsätzlich nicht
gegen abtreibung
das ist für mich das wichtigste thema
und ich bin amerikaner
das halte ich für ein privileg viele
menschen wollen nach amerika kommen aber
mir scheint es so dass diejenigen die
jetzt hier leben den kurs des landes
verändern wollen und da bin ich voll und
ganz dagegen
ich glaube es gibt eine stille mehrheit
und eine laute minderheit
wenn die minderheit arbeiten würde so
wie wir hätten sie zum beispiel nicht
die zeit zu randalieren und sachen
niederzubrennen
so sehe ich das und ich danke dem herrn
dass ich in amerika meine meinung äußern
darf
trumps mantra verschenkt recht und
ordnung der beiden welt stimmt für chaos
wie in portland bei den gewalttätigen
ausschreitungen so die logik das sieht
auch calvin so der ex marin hat sich
seinen amerikanischen traum erfüllt eine
whisky brennerei bei der er selbst hand
anlegt politisch steht er zu trump große
ansprüche an die regierung hat er wie
viele hier nicht ich möchte einfach in
ruhe gelassen werden
ja ich denke die meisten leute sind doch
in der lage auf sich selbst aufzupassen
ich glaube am nächstenliebe und wer kann
sollte geld für andere spenden sollte
der staat eine krankenversicherung für
alle anbieten
das kann ich nicht beantworten darauf
habe ich keine haben sie eine
krankenversicherung ist vom büro durchs
militär das ist alles was ich habe also
eine minimalversorgung ich weiß es nicht
ich habe sie noch nie in anspruch
genommen und ihre angestellten sind die
versichert das weiß ich nicht
fragen über die sich kerben wenig
gedanken macht jeder ist seines glückes
schmied und harte arbeit zahlt sich aus
daran glaubt er
wie viele in amerika seinen neuen
angestellten produzieren verschiedene
produkte auf seiner farm zum beispiel
selbstgemachten senkt den er einmal die
woche bis nach washington bringt das
sind 120 meilen bis auf den markt und
der nähe von washington fahren sie etwa
zweieinhalb stunden ein weg ja es lohnt
sich für uns
im selben ort lernen wir kennen auch er
ist durch und durch geschäftsmann der
baumarkt sein ganzer stolz
jeff ist republikaner hat auch für trapp
gestimmt im moment läuft sein laden wie
geschmiert die hilfsgelder aus
washington wegen der pandemie führen zu
rekord umsätze gut für sein geschäft
aber als konservative ist er eigentlich
gegen die hohe staatsverschuldung
es hat uns total geholfen
es kamen leute rein die für zwei monate
entlassen wurden und trotzdem ihr ganzes
geld ausgaben
ich dachte mir nur an ihrer stelle würde
ich zu hause bleiben muss man geld
sparen
im geschäft war jedenfalls vieles
ausverkauft erde unkraut fresser
kettensägen so etwas hatten wir noch nie
sogar tiefkühl tun denn das ganze geld
zurückzahlen unsere kinder
romney west virginia hat schon bessere
zeiten erlebt die kleinstadt war die
erste stolze städtische ansiedlung im
bundesstaat vor 238 jahren
das durchschnittseinkommen heute fast
ein viertel niedriger als im rest das
land ist die bürgermeisterin eine
demokraten kann das phänomen kramp nicht
nachvollziehen
er hatte neue jobs versprochen aber wir
haben hier keine neuen jobs bekommt er
hatte steuersenkungen versprochen doch
die steuererleichterungen die es gab
waren am ende tatsächlich
steuererhöhungen die
steuererleichterungen gingen nur an
firmen unternehmen konzerne nicht an die
kleinen leute die hier in der stadt
leben
ich glaube dass einige leute erkennen
dass er nicht umgesetzt hat was er
versprochen hat und trotzdem meine ich
dass viele ihn wahrscheinlich immer noch
unterstützen
wir sind an der örtlichen tankstelle
auch hier hält man zu trump und anti
nach mund und nasenschutz fehlanzeige
die pandemie wird nicht ernst genommen
weiß bridging us-gouverneur auch ein
tramp unterstützer hat verfügt
anderthalb meter abstand reiche aus
maske nicht nötig drinnen auch nicht
eben laden alles was das herz begehrt
waffen inklusive auf dem land für die
meisten ein muss man braucht doch nur
die nachrichten verfolgen
dann weiß man bescheid es gibt bestimmte
leute in der politik die uns die waffen
wegnehmen wollen aber wer soll uns
beschützen wenn wir uns selbst nicht
mehr verteidigen können
ich meine es kann eine halbe stunde
dauern bis ein polizist aus und dann
wäre es einfach
waffen zur selbstverteidigung eine
amerikanische tradition die die schmidts
so nicht teilen statt über
unterschiedliche positionen zu
diskutieren regt die älteste unter ihnen
trumps politikstil am meisten auf sie
ist 94 und hält ihn für gefährlich ich
kann mich noch gut an den zweiten
weltkrieg erinnern an hitler
ich weiß noch wie er vorgegangen ist und
was trump jetzt tot ist genau das
gleiche
für mich gibt es keinen unterschied und
ich denke das ist extrem gefährlich
alles was er getan hat ist kriminell er
hat den gesamten regierungsapparat
ruiniert er ersetzte berufsdiplomaten
durch leute die ihm geld gaben und das
steckt seine familie ein tramp ist das
klima rauer geworden die schwelle der
toleranz hat sich verschoben die
politischen gräben tief wie noch nie
doch die beiden jüngeren der familie
schmidt sehen das entspannter
amerikanisch locker jeder kann seine
meinung äußern
das ist das schöne an einer demokratie
wenn du eine meinung hast darfst du sie
kund tun bis zu einem gewissen grad
und trotzdem ein riss geht durch die
amerikanische gesellschaft das
zwei-parteien-system lässt wenig raum
für zwischentöne der sich mit
republikaner oder demokraten
identifiziert steht am ende zum
spitzenkandidaten egal wer es ist
jeder demokrat ist mir recht ist mir
völlig egal wer hauptsache ein demokrat
ich habe damals in erster linie gegen
hillary clinton gestimmt trump war die
einzig andere optionen und jetzt
wir haben die wahl zwischen einem mann
der einen kotau also eine verbeugung
nach links macht nach links außen als
wir haben die wahl zwischen entweder
einem marxisten oder du hältst du trump
und hofft dass er in den nächsten vier
jahren die stellung hält bisher ein
moderaterer hatte ein bisschen mehr
sprachkenntnissen ins amt kommt und uns
wieder nach vorne unüberbrückbare
differenzen trotz mancher zweifel ist es
trump gelungen sich als einer von ihnen
darzustellen einen kämpfer für den
kleinen mann gegen die elite die
konservative basis jedenfalls steht
hinter ihm